[Musik]
was würde franz josef strauß eigentlich
über sie sagen
er wird sagen das ist das neue
konservativ ist das für sie ein vorbild
franz josef strauß ja ein vorbild ist es
halt einer der in der csu vieles bewegt
hat und wo ich auch mich mitunter dafür
entschieden haben in die csu einzutreten
und ja ich habe auch eine büste von
franz josef strauß bei mir zu hause
und wie findet markus söder das wissen
sie dass das weiß ich nicht das muss man
ihn selber fragen wie er das findet
lassen sie uns über die ja vielleicht
den religiösen hintergrund dieser partei
sprechen was an der csu heutzutage
würden sie sagen ist denn überhaupt
christlich oder noch christlich also ich
glaube die cs wo ist eine partei des
christlichen menschenbildes und der
christlichen werte wenn man die csu als
nur christliche partei versteht wohl nur
katholiken und protestanten
mitmachen dürfen dann glaube ich ist es
einer partei so in der form nicht würdig
man muss die lebenswirklichkeit und auch
die gesellschaftsstruktur die wir
heutzutage haben auch innerhalb einer
parteienlandschaft widerspiegeln und ich
glaube das macht die csu und sie wissen
ja auch selber das in den letzten tagen
auch die parteiführung das ganz klar und
deutlich unterstrichen hat das dass die
das auch unterstützen das muslimische
mitbürger und auch türkischstämmige
mitbürger in der csu eine rolle spielen
können aber ich sage auch ganz klar und
deutlich es gibt auch in deutschland
bestimmte richtungen und schwingungen
die wir natürlich innerhalb der partei
auch verhindern müssen wenn es
beispielsweise und das sage ich ganz
klar und deutlich wenn es beispielsweise
leute gibt die den erdogan huldigen und
die beispielsweise bei der die tipps
sind dann würde ich sagen ist es nicht
kompatibel mit den werten unserer csu
aber wir haben es schon angesprochen vor
zwei wochen hat der china sahin hat
seine kandidatur zurück
zogen weil scheinbar die csu dann doch
nicht überall so weit ist hat sie das
entmutigt ermutigt betroffen
ja ich war erschüttert als ich das
gehört habe
wallerstein ist eine kleine gemeinde in
schwaben und ich hätte mir ja mehr
weitblick von den funktionären gewünscht
aber ich war immer einer der die
herausforderungen die liebt hat ehrlich
gesagt und es hat mich erschüttert aber
ich habe zwei möglichkeiten gehabt ich
habe auch in der vergangenheit immer
wieder gegenwind gehabt und es wäre
falsch wenn ich sagen würde nein es gab
kein gegenwind innerhalb der csu
natürlich aber dann habe ich zwei
möglichkeiten gehabt die eine
möglichkeit ist zu resignieren und die
andere möglichkeit wahr und die habe ich
auch befolgt mich der herausforderung zu
stellen hat sich dagegen momentan
geäußert von denen sie sprechen ja im
grunde was so wenn sie im ortsverband
oder kreisverband bestimmte arbeiten
gemacht haben war es einfach so dass man
gut dafür war schluss plakate kleben
wenn es dann aber darum ging letzten
endes um bestimmte posten dann hat man
mir doch eher nahe gelegt und das nicht
jeder sondern wirklich vereinzelte nach
unseren du bist ein super kerl aber
dieses amt das er zu hoch für dich und
die menschen im ländlichen raum das
könnten wir überhaupt nicht darstellen
und denen das erklären und wie hat man
das begründet ja wegen der herkunft auch
und das hat mich tief getroffen ehrlich
gesagt dass meine herkunft die große
rolle spielt um bestimmte politische
ämter nicht zu bekleiden und ich habe
dann immer gesagt nein es stehen die
kompetenzen entsteht das menschliche im
vordergrund und ich habe mich dann auch
wirklich mit der zeit durchgesetzt und
die menschen von mir überzeugt und das
ist auch genau der punkt wo ich in
zukunft die eben menschen mit
migrationsgeschichte zu rufen kann man
darf nicht sofort resignieren sondern
man muss sie sich wirklich den dingen
stellen und nicht gleich lapidar sagen
ja er hat jetzt eine falsche oder nicht
so gute meinung über mich und dann
sofort resignieren ich glaube das ist
falsche weg da werden wir in zukunft die
gesellschaft nicht in eine gute richtung
führen können und die kluft zwischen von
beiden seiten wird immer heftiger
können sie denn stück weit verstehen
dass es da vielleicht widerstand gab
wenn man bedenkt dass in bayern selbst
ein evangelischer ministerpräsident oder
besitzer selbst das war mal ein
tabubruch
dass es da widerstände gibt wenn ein
muslim bürgermeister werden will
selbstverständlich also es ist es ist
einfach so die partei hat sich ja auch
entwickelt wie sie es eben gesagt haben
früher wenn man von gälisch war war das
schwierig irgendwelche parteiämter zu
bekommen oder karten csu
parteivorsitzender zu werden heute
einmal einen csu-parteivorsitzenden der
der die partei führt und der evangelisch
ist und wir haben viele funktionäre die
wirklich auch ministerposten haben oder
generalsekretäre sind und das begrüße
ich sehr
aber wir müssen das eben weiter führen
und wenn wir das nicht weiter führen
dann verlieren wir auch menschen und wir
haben beispielsweise wenn ich nur über
die türkischstämmigen reden darf das
sind dessen 3,2 millionen die verlieren
ja einfach auch und aber wir haben auch
große zustimmungswerte es war immer so
dass die spd die grünen die partei waren
die muslime und türkischstämmige
angezogen haben mittlerweile gab es da
auch eine umkehr
sie haben gesagt dass die csu habe sich
entwickelt heisst dass der christliche
glaube in der partei spielt heute kaum
noch eine rolle
selbstverständlich spielt es eine große
rolle aber wir müssen politik und
religion voneinander trennen deswegen
sage ich es ist eine partei die csu habe
ich einmal heißt du mal christlich
kabarett und freundlich aber ja ja aber
es ist keine christliche sekte also das
muss man schon unterscheiden weil ich
stelle dann auch die frage die sagen wir
sind eine christliche partei oder gar
nicht sicher sagt er manche denken das
ja was ist dann der unterschied ehrlich
gesagt von beispielsweise einer partei
in der türkei die akp vom erdogan die
auch politik und religion miteinander
vermischt und das möchte ich hier
deutschland ehrlich gesagt nicht wir
wollen das christliche menschenbild die
christlichen werte natürlich in unserer
handlung mit einfließen lassen ganz klar
und da stehe ich auch dazu
aber wir sind keine christliche sekte es
ist nicht so lange her dass
ministerpräsident söder den kreuz las
für ganz bayern ja erlassen hat würden
sie sich das kreuz 1 am zimmer hängen ja
ich habe da kein problem mit ich mag
zwar ehrlich gesagt keine symbolpolitik
und ich fand diesen kreuz erlass ehrlich
gesagt
kurz vor den wahlen eher symbolisch und
ich denke die menschen erwarten von uns
er die lösungen von herausforderungen
die wir in unserer gesellschaft haben
und davon haben wir genug und aber um
ihre frage zu beantworten ich hätte ein
problem weil ich in einem land lebe das
einfach auch christlich geprägt ist dass
ich in meinem amtszimmer natürlich dann
auch ein kreuz habe hat sich dank
heribert letzte frage gibt es
irgendetwas was die bayern die
mehrheitlich katholischen bayern vom
islam lernen können weil ich glaube es
gibt ja nicht den islam und es gibt auch
nicht das christentum ich glaube dass
das menschliche in den vordergrund
stellen gestellt werden soll
und ich glaube wenn man beide religionen
miteinander vergleicht das ist der
falsche weg es müssen die personen und
die die kompetenzen im vordergrund
stehen und das überlasse ich den
theologen dass die den islam und das
christentum miteinander dann vergleichen
ist es dann vielleicht auch ein stück
weit gott weil zum beispiel bei anderen
csu mitgliedern fragt er kein mensch ob
wir jetzt wirklich gläubig sind oder wie
gläubig mann ist wie sie sagen sollte
keine rolle spielen ist es dann wie gott
dass man überhaupt über die
religionszugehörigkeit spricht ja
selbstverständlich und es ist auch so
mittlerweile stehe ich drüber aber es
tut auch weh dass man einfach nur auf
die herkunft und auch die religion
reduziert wird und das muss sich einfach
ändern und wenn sich das nicht ändert
werden wir auch den gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalt in zukunft nicht stärken
können und deshalb erwarte ich auch
einer partei und ehrlich gesagt das muss
von den parteifunktionären gelebt werden
nicht nur zu sagen ich bedaure ist und
es kann einen bürgermeister einen muslim
auch bürgermeister werden sondern man
muss das auch in handlungen ummünzen
dass jemand landrat werden kann dass
jemand staatsminister wird dass jemand
auch csu parteivorsitzender werden kann
herzlichen dank rosa ribas dass sie sich
unseren fragen heute früh gestellt haben
einen spannenden wahlkampf in neufahrn
herzlichen dank dass sie bei uns waren
10 herzlichen dank auch schönen tag noch
dank ihnen auch
[Musik]